i've known her a long time please
welcome she's here in person natasha
[Applause]
i feel like one of the last hard hangs i
had
before the world changed was with you
yes we hung hard we hung hard
walking the streets of downtown new york
having deep conversations and yet we met
when we were i mean as the in the words
of patty smith just kids just kids we
did a film together in night was it 1996
i think so it may have even been 95. but
it was 96. you were just you were like
my you know still and but i was maybe
like 15 or something i think you were
like 20. so to me you were just the
coolest girl in the world you're just
ultimate rebel
and then we played half sisters yes and
i remember that the first time i met you
it was the first time this happened you
hear about a lot now people even say it
to me for some reason because i'd seen
you on that big screen in my mind you
were like a hundred feet tall and then
this little person came out and you came
out and you all were like you hugged me
and we were shooting a scene in a
funeral home yeah everybody was saying
uh enjoy yourself it's later than you
think and you were like hello and i was
like oh my god she's little like me it's
so funny yeah it's true i think one of
the number one comments i hear from
people
is oh you're so short
yeah
and i'm like i guess i am the other one
people love is they're always like wow
you're much better looking in person
i get that all the time
i don't think it is
i can't tell but i think they mean it as
that like it's a icebreaker yeah but
it's also like a confidence breaker it's
also like you photographed terribly
congratulations on your chosen
profession yeah
everything all your choices are wrong
but
your hair is the best hair on planet
earth come on it's
i don't know if you can really tell but
i have a mullet right now oh my god i'm
trying to i feel like the last time i
saw you i got up in it too oh yeah it's
the best hair in the world does it make
you happy some days you know oh come on
but
i have really good hair a good hair days
i mean there's uh marcel de janet who
does the hair on russian doll he really
he was the one that really said to me
uh no we're not styling you're wearing
it we're gonna own the natural texture
if we're gonna you know keep it really
red
a heavy bang and i think i was so scared
you know of like
almost being myself i think i was and it
was
such a weird process uh
the the the warmth like the positivity
of the response of rash and all that the
more
i leaned into sort of my natural true
self and
got away from this idea of like pulling
it straight and i don't mean like for
fun or for fashion but i mean
as an you know uh
an alternate persona or something this
idea that i had to be away that i was
not and
it really really helped me i think well
i think when you
also
play a character which i heard you want
to do pesci is that true oh yeah i
always i always love the boys i see
i see pesci and goodfellas i'm like that
he stole my part you know
would you ever play him in a movie
if it came up i would i i think it would
be scary to do but i would do it anyway
you as joe pesci needs to happen okay i
think it's okay well i like that
everybody almost applauded and they were
like we're not sure
and i appreciate that honesty from you
guys because i don't know that we're
short either you are everything you can
do there's nothing you can't do you as
pesci i just think needs to happen or
his daughter but i want you especially
thank you finally
i'm so glad
you know as you guys know i'm here
promoting my peshy biopic
i did it with no hair and makeup i said
come as you are and i just moved through
all the beats of his life and you know
you'll see the film and tell me what you
think i have a working title yeah what's
that peshy
boom it's done that's it it's done
that's it
[Music]
you